[Music]
the pavot nation has been here while
I've heard tribal leaders say from
millennia they called us Nomads but
Nomads just wander we went with the
seasons the tribe used the river like
its own highway so that was our road
system and that's where our traditional
fishing was it was all kinds of fish
like Sealand prey we ate sturgeon
striper bass everything that runs up the
river now those are our traditional fish
so that's why we look at her as a
relative a sister someone that gives
life my name is Jan Paul I work for the
panop Scot nation in the Department of
Natural Resources water
quality I was born and raised on Indian
Island I have lived here my entire life
growing up on Indianland was poor but
close-knitted my mother and father
ingrained in us a fear for the river
because she's so powerful that she would
take you if you got too close so when we
were younger we had that fear but then
as I got older you know you you could
smell her sometimes and on the edge it
was stinky and and so as I got this
opportunity to work for the tribe then
that's when I started noticing yeah our
river is really polluted and I did my
first summer and that's when I saw an
algae bloom during the day they come to
the surface to get the light so they're
getting all their oxygen from the Sun
and then when the Sun starts to go down
they sink to the bottom they take all
the oxygen out of the water column so
that what that does is they put strain
on the Aquatic Life but especially the
fish so they won't be able to breathe
and so you'll see fish kills when you
see someone you love getting polluted
not by choice but just by the they they
breathe or someone's putting in
something in your water it just it's
heart
[Music]
ing but all the Mills above us now are
gone once we were able to be viewed as
people and started getting help from the
United States that's when we started
taking care of her in the sense that we
started our water quality monitoring
program our data was going on a piece
piece of paper and it would take years
to get into our database it was tough
getting our data in and tough getting it
out there's this story about me losing
all my data sheets the wind took them
off my clipboard and they went floating
down the
river and you can't recreate data once
you're there it's it's going to be
different cuz it's a flowing
river but then we went paperless from
the field we checked in to what we call
the workstation from the workstation and
then would send it off to the lab so
they could add their data in and then
from the lab permanently stored in our
database which we use our studio to
write code to pull it out so we can run
reports and do graphs and stuff like
that open- Source tools and posit help
keep us fast and efficient in dealing
with the health of the pancot
river our data has showed Department of
of Environmental Protection couple of
sections of the river is meeting a
different classification and so the
upgrades were passed in
2019 my hopes for the river's future is
that she's healthy in the sense that
when she's healthy we're healthy and so
the healthier she is the healthier we
are as a
people
[Music]
[Applause]